gimli
the dwarf to legolas the elf
that still only counts as [ __ ] one
see
that's a good one
have you found one nailed i've got one
here on my
instagram uh from jamiesmart93 what's
happening jamie smart who says i'll do
my best to make ellen impression here a
wizard is never like fruity baggins nor
is he earlier he arrives precisely when
he means to not bad not bad
i took i took a a photo of a few because
i liked them and you know how like i
like tree beard ones for something yeah
you said so uh a tree beard
side i am on nobody's side because
nobody is on my
side little lock
that's nice love it
this one from roz linen i actually think
this works pretty well and you know you
could have put it in there earwin in
return of the king
i am no
man now that actually works quite that
that actually works as a you know i mean
you put that in and you think yeah fair
enough hey i forgot to say it was josh
curtis who did the tree beard one and
i'm gonna i'm gonna do this is my last
one though okay because i like this
great red spot
said uh a galadriel quote oh yes in
place of a dark lord you would have a
queen
that's a good one all right i'll end
with this one because you know how much
i love pippin in those movies this from
frank.saber
pippin in fellowship of the ring all
right where are we going
send in more of your suggestions we love
those things
[Music]
you're shining bright i'm your boy's the
baby you're my
[Music]